[Musique]
wes craven vous pensez toujours à lui comme
le roi de l'horreur c'est un
réalisateur incroyable mais c'est aussi un
humain incroyable je pourrais commencer à pleurer quand on commence à
parler de wes il était comme un père
à bien des égards pour nous tous  wes craven
m'a appelé chez lui c'était notre
première rencontre il allait me donner des
notes sur le script
et c'étaient toutes des fautes de frappe
c'était la beauté de wes craven il
était une âme si gentille
nous sommes des fans à un niveau difficile à
exprimer
qu'il a fait
des films d'horreur cool et effrayants en quelque sorte vous emmener autour d'une action de
montagnes russes
prête et ann
alors quand j'ai eu le script pour le nouvel
écran
j'ai été vraiment impressionné par matt et tyler
avec combien wes avait eu une impression
sur lui
tout ce que nous avions droit  ce film est à
cause de wes craven
bonjour
voudriez-vous jouer à un jeu
tara
sid ça se reproduit
j'avais eu peur d'en faire
un autre sans wes mais matt et
tyler voulaient vraiment l'honorer c'est
amusant d'y retourner j'ai fait  F  nos
flux avec wes craven j'étais comme oh
wow quel moyen parfait de réinventer ce
film
ils aiment l'original
ils veulent honorer wes
et c'est tellement effrayant de voir
comment ce nouveau casting se connecte à l'héritage
qu'il a
c'est ce qui va rendre ce film
super spécial
et j'espérais qu'ils allaient
dédier le film à l'ouest
et ils l'ont fait
[Musique]
toi